in today's agile business environment
business analysis holds the key to
unlocking the real value of business
data organizations all over the world
are looking for business analysts who
can use the wealth of data available and
employ Cutting Edge techniques to reveal
actionable insights for increasing
Revenue productivity and efficiency
across the Enterprise
hi I'm Ravi bhapna the Curtis L Carlson
chair of business analytics at the
Carlton School of Management University
of Minnesota
welcome to the postgraduate program in
business analytics offered by the
Carlton School in collaboration with
simply love
since its establishment in 1919
the University of Minnesota's Carlson
School of Management has been a leader
in business education has served as a
beacon of knowledge for the world's
business community
in this postgraduate program in business
Analytics
you'll learn the theoretical
underpinnings of analytics and gain the
Practical know-how to quickly and
successfully apply the right tools and
techniques to new problems tackled by
business today
with this program you stand to learn and
master all the key skills needed by a
business analyst today understand the
tools and techniques used in business
analysis planning and monitoring learn
powerful Ms Excel skills to leverage
business analytics and make better
business decisions learn and apply
essential statistical and SQL Concepts
gain an in-depth understanding of R and
learn to write your own R scripts Define
understand and use apply functions in
dplyr functions understand and use the
hypothesis testing method linear and
non-linear regression models and
classification techniques learn to
visualize data using Tableau and power
bi and much more
along with Carlson's expertise
simplylearn's applied learning approach
provides the best elements of
traditional classroom education
delivered online Blended learning
combines self-paced e-learning
instructor-led live virtual classrooms
Hands-On labs and projects with 24 7
learning support what's more simply
learns platform provides ample
peer-to-peer interaction with your
fellow learners this program fits into
your budget and your schedule you access
all aspects of the program from your own
home or office and the cost is a
fraction of tuition and expenses of an
equivalent on-campus program what are
you waiting for get in touch with one of
our program advisors who will walk you
through the application process